as coven 19 vaccines start being
distributed around the world
scams for the products are proliferating
from phishing emails to ads on the dark
net
some of these offer phony pfizer or
moderna vaccines that can cost as much
as fifteen hundred dollars
once there is a big demand on something
there's starting to be a black market
officials and researchers around the
world are worried about the implications
for public health
and people's personal information for
instance in december the department of
homeland security said it had taken down
a fake moderna website
which appeared to have been used for
fraud and spreading malware
as it gets to be more broadly applicable
we feel
the concerns for for counterfeit in fake
vaccines will be even more pronounced
while pfizer didn't respond to her
request for comment moderna said its
only sales have been to governments
which are working closely with medical
providers to control and secure
the first batches of the coven 19
vaccine so a legitimate
vaccine is unlikely to be sold online by
dubious sources
so far us authorities say that there
have been no reports of fake vaccines
being delivered to customers
so how do counterfeit coven 19 vaccines
end up online
and what are the risks for people who
buy them
u.s health officials say there may be
enough vaccines for the general public
this spring or summer
and in the future clinics and insurers
in various parts of the world can make
vaccines available for purchase
but for some people this may seem too
far away there is
effort from governments to achieve
vaccine for their people
but there is limited number of vaccine
in general oded vanunu is a security
researcher based in israel
and companies hire him to look for and
fix breaches in their networks
recently he's been tracking the sale of
coven 19 vaccines on the dark net
a term used to refer to hidden parts of
the internet which require an encrypted
browser such as tor to access
all sorts of holistic goods from drugs
to weapons can be traded on these
digital black markets
pharmaceuticals on the dark net
eventually surface on illicit platforms
that look like legitimate e-commerce or
government websites
the new news team has found more than
700 new vaccine-related websites that
have cropped up since november
consumers can end up on these through
links sent in emails or messaging apps
you think that you buy like from a
legitimate place
but you will get the merchandise from
the dark neck
fandunu says the best way to spot a
counterfeit is to have information
about the real vaccine for instance some
darknet vendors venue spoke to
incorrectly stated that the pfizer
vaccine doesn't need to be stored in
super freezers at minus 70 degrees
celsius
and shipped in dry ice one of the
vendors told us you don't need
a minus 70 degree you need minus
10 and you can put it on the freezer
fanunni said he reached out to one
vendor who was selling a vaccine
developed in china
but had no brand a batch of 14 doses
could be delivered within two weeks and
was priced
at 0.01 bitcoin the equivalent of about
250 dollars in december
he purchased 700 worth of this product
for research purposes
but two weeks later it had not arrived
we hopefully it will come in
the coming weeks but if a fake vaccine
that was ordered online actually arrives
there are risks for the buyer a
counterfeit
manufacturer doesn't really have the
knowledge nor the understanding
of all of that processes that are
necessary to create
safe and effective products mansour
amici is a pharmacist who works with
vaccine developers in
international agencies to track the
global trade of illicit drugs and
medical products
in europe for example between march and
september authorities seized more than
33 million fake medical devices
and eight tons of illicit
pharmaceuticals european authorities
warned fake vaccine sellers could do the
same
they may mix water or they may create
some colored liquid to to mirror what
looks like a vaccine and then put a
label on top that looks very similar the
moderna or frizer label
one of the biggest risks of being
inoculated with fake vaccines
is that these substances could be toxic
and cause side effects
eventually undermining people's trust in
the real coven 19 vaccine
at a time when many around the world are
already skeptical
for instance a survey shows that the
percentage of people who strongly or
somewhat agreed they would get the
vaccine
decreased in december anyone who gets
inoculated with a fake vaccine
may also have a false sense of security
that may leave them vulnerable to
infection
while also raising the risk of
transmission to others
so for vaccination campaigns to be
effective in fighting the virus
a vast majority of the population will
need to get safe vaccines